We talked about earthquakes earlier on in the course. And now we are going to
talk about that something that's measured in a very similar way. Surprisingly
this is sound. Sound is also measured on a logarithmic scale. And we can use
this equation to help us out. This says L1 equals 10 times log base 10 of P
over B. Now here, B is some reference volume. it's just a constant that we're
going to eliminate eventually, so we don't need to worry about what it's
actually equal to. The two variables we have are important, though. P is what
is known as the power of the sound, and L here, or I'm calling it L1 in this
case, is a measure of the sound level. This is basically comparing the sound
power P to B. Now, you may have heard about different sounds being dangerous to
our hearing. And this equation can actually help us quantify that. L here, is
measured in decibels or dB. And looking at the decibels ratings of different
sounds it seems like a pretty small increase in the number of decibels.
Actually amounts to a pretty big increase in potential damage. So why is this?
Well, let's look at a few other questions to figure this out. So if the
original sound power that we're talking about is p, as written in this
equation, what will we need to use in its place if we wanted to talk about a
sound with double that power